I'm an attention arbitrage entrepreneur
[Music]
we are The Breakfast Club got a special
guest in the bill my favorite corporate
dog motivators back the next trend is
meditation if you want to get real smart
so back to hey give us a practical piece
of advice if you're intrigued by mental
hell I'm super intrigued by this so I
think mental health needs to be the
number one thing we talk about over the
next 20 years mental health is something
we need to put on a pedestal and really
start talking about meditation is a huge
opportunity
everybody's gonna be doing it if your
operating system isn't right if your
brains not right nothing else is gonna
work if you're a business person if
you're starting a juice company if
you're trying to flip sneakers and it's
a hundred percent about the money you're
gonna lose em if you don't love your
process if you don't love eating the
[ __ ] along the way you got zero shots to
hit that huge level if you don't like
taking a thousand free-throws if you
don't like being in the office until
midnight if you don't like waiting in
line for six hours in the cold to get
that thing you're finished the people
that are winning are the ones who wake
up at 4:30 take two trains and get third
in line and love it Gary Vee ladies my
guy it's the breakfast collision morning
what's up blog really in the midst of
things
tomorrow's the big day the launch of my
sneaker and my Jackie Robinson year
number 42 so looking forward to that by
the time you watch this it was already
my birthday so in the comments you can
go with happy belated
[Music]
as far as tasting [ __ ] is concerned I
want to taste as much of it as I can in
as many places as I can
interesting what I'm gonna do is travel
the world I love it
so what's the plan in detail when do you
start traveling January so what are you
going beijing and what are you doing
there teaching three or five year old
kids English I love it I love your
thoughts on this idea with personal
branding in mind I realized that I don't
necessarily want to be the person
marketing someone else what market
yourself i want to market myself I
understand that yeah okay I obviously
need to like have time where I can say
something worth of value that actually
tells you or you document versus
creating right I think it's super
appropriate for you to talk about the
one year in China and like you know get
a homie to help you or you do it
yourself like Casey does of like all
those journeys and learnings and
struggling with learning Mandarin and I
didn't know how hard languages were you
know oh my god this kid in my class
understood English in one day he's a
[ __ ] genius or I tasted this fruit
and what the [ __ ] the big thing that I
push against and this is good clarity
for everybody watching and you is just
you know when people front and they
think they're a business expert or a
life coach at 22 it's tough it's tough
because other people look at that and
saying yeah you know what listen talent
is talent maybe you are so wise I feel
like I was an old soul so maybe you can
be a life coach at 22 it's not for me to
judge I think that people do it for the
sake of selling some program for $1,000
a month which is in my eye and by the
way that doesn't bother me either it's
just that I see a lot of people building
a personal brand with one agenda to then
monetize that audience in some sort of
horseshit thing so to me I don't think
you have to eat [ __ ] for a decade and
like you don't do my narrative I'm not
sure if I would have stayed quiet from
22 to 34 if all this existed but what I
do know is I wouldn't be acting the way
I'm acting now I'd be talking about
first of all I wish it happened because
then everybody would have really saw how
[ __ ] hard I was working but I think
it's super appropriate to document man I
think the documentation creates the
origins
when you can recall [ __ ] at 29 or 34 and
literally play the clip of the first
time that you used a are in Asia got it
that's why it's important when people
don't realize about what I'm doing right
now is this is [ __ ] awesome ten years
from now this makes this look like [ __ ]
when I'm recalling [ __ ] and recalling
the rear oh yeah do you know crazy it's
gonna be one [ __ ] voice rules the
world and I showed this entire [ __ ]
year of me spitting it it's one thing
for me it happened the other day
those musically tweets late at night of
me talking about musically two years ago
and putting musically on and believing
in it and then it sells for a billion
dollars a hell of a lot better than when
I tell people like I invested in
Facebook and Twitter cuz that's me
telling you be showing you plus it's
also cool for life
your Korean kids are you kidding in
China yeah it's [ __ ] rad yeah you
know so I would create as much content
as possible that would be my advice it's
a real pleasure man good luck to you
thanks for everything yeah
[Music]
anything I can help you with in a few
minutes they'll be happier because
concern right now is getting the team so
it's hard to hire people what actually
skillful at the right price cuz like can
you teach you quickly yes and now I feel
like let me ask a better question can
you fire quickly are you allowed in
China to fire then that's what you've
done you're lucky if you were in [ __ ]
Norway or or Europe France you're dead
with my thesis I've got a great answer
for you fire quickly if I'm giving you
my advice eating my own dog food I go on
gut Kyle I keep pointing through this is
filming when I went on gut had a phone
call with the medics rink in a bar with
it I'm like you're hired if he sucked it
for was all time it would have both made
sense to me if I fire quickly he'll work
for me for nine weeks but I'll give him
a three months severance so I feel like
I'm a good guy you know so I didn't [ __ ]
him up too much or I'll know their
situation like if I hire somebody who
like had no options in life I'm like
look it's not like I took him away from
a Harvard Business School you know I'll
play the reality of the situation I
think that's what you do man you fire
quickly
what up everybody hope you guys are
doing your thing
one life baby take advantage of thank
you
[Music]
yo yo yo yo yo sup bro what up baby this
is the ambassador of arbitrage the the
harem leader of Hustle yo Chuck is in
the booth what's up man
life is good man thanks for having me my
legacy of like putting people on and
bringing value while I got mine is gonna
matter exponentially more to me than the
dollar amounts you listen there's a lot
of people are gonna make more money than
me but I really really am gonna try to
make sure nobody has a bigger impact
than me
blast you it's why I'm passionate about
doing stuff like this
I after doing a quick audit and kind of
intuition of like I knew I wanted to do
it give a pumped I am I'm doing the show
do you know why no cuz I want you to use
me as a guest of this to get a different
level of guests to get you to the next
place I know where I came from and
giving back to that thing is the most
interesting thing in the world and the
amount of in a world where my hour is my
[ __ ] you know to me if you ask me the
thing that's most interesting for me
it's the emails you're gonna send to the
other people or the people when they
look or you know yeah
brand arbitrage I think my bigger
advantage was my mother if you asked me
what's a bigger advantage to why I'm
gonna win yeah it is way more my mother
than being a white dude cuz she [ __ ]
set me up yeah real proper yeah so so I
think your mother and I'm talk about
everybody who's watching right or your
father if he was to stay at home whoever
raised you right let's go cliche or your
grandmother right let me go to every
angle right right yeah that is a bigger
is a crazy variable in the way that I
see the world the person that was the
puppet master of your mindset positive
or negative
my grandmother [ __ ] my dad up real
good and my dad won right but she was
negative
everything was bad don't believe in
anybody everybody's jealous everything
is bad the world's out to get you and
watching my dad filter the world I'm
like luck man I'm glad I don't see the
world that way and that has nothing to
do with black white girl boy so that's
how I see it everybody's reality is
their reality yeah like they don't know
like it's tough to Tuffy nobody can be
in anybody's shoes no but nobody was
with me when I was crying to my mom like
I'm 18 I would cry to my mom a lot is
the last time I really cried a lot
except when garrison Hearst broke a
99-yard touchdown in 1999 against the
Jets in week one in overtime I literally
cried I was 24 years old just everybody
understands anyway I didn't want to go
into my dad's liquor store business the
great struggle of my early adult life
was knowing that God I knew I was gonna
be all-time great knew it I knew it and
I knew that if I went and got into my
dad's liquor store business that people
would dangle it over my head but I knew
that I wanted to do right by my dad and
mom cuz they did so right by me to ever
apologize when you don't do the wrong
thing is a wrong strategy and by the way
on the flip side I love those rare
occasions when I get to say sorry cuz
I'll say it you got older you're [ __ ]
nobody [ __ ] listening and watching
this is perfect baseball cards wine the
agency and even me as a human I'm doing
the same [ __ ] over and over i dis
proportionally understand what people
are gonna do before they do it yeah I'm
willing to eat [ __ ] and do the work not
just pontificate about it right and then
I deploy that attention of those
executions against the thing and then I
got smart seven years ago to set the
[ __ ] let me build a machine around this
skill vaynermedia is the manifestation
of a platform that is basically my one
thing and my one thing is intuitive
understanding of what people are gonna
do before they do it and going all in
investing in Twitter and you know
and tumblr and all this stuff right
that's what I did if you were to die
tomorrow what would you want to be
remembered for that I gave more than I
took I have a thing that I'm doing that
I started when it comes to education
called black boys win almost like a
udemy for young black boys you know
manhood training things that interesting
what do you think I do what I need to do
to raise the funds cuz I've got how much
you need right now I need the 15 grand
I'm in I'm sorry what I'll pay for the
whole thing
get the [ __ ] out of here I'm in put
[ __ ] now do something with it oh man
trust me oh well that's amazing my thank
you you're welcome thank you baby thank
you you're welcome bro preciate that see
you
[Music]
what's the name again Nicole hey it's
Gary Vaynerchuk in your new askgaryvee
show with Tim Ferriss if your tried and
true the market will come to you what is
super interesting to me about hip hop is
it is now a absolute fundamental pillar
of our culture across all genres and it
stayed true to itself it evolved but the
world came to hip hop hip hop didn't go
to the world and and then I realized as
I got older a rock and roll did the same
thing and honestly that's what happened
with me and entrepreneurship if you
believe in your thing stick with it and
the world will come to you if you're
passionate about cricket proteins
it's not a joke by the way now there's
actually something I think is gonna work
out if you're passionate about cricket
protein bet the farm on it because if
you see it and you understand why you
see it it's gonna be a lot of fun in 9
years when we're all eating it and you
were there not because it's not selling
right now most of the things that have
brought good to Tim and I cuz I could
definitely speak for myself and I've
watched from afar and sometimes close
with him people weren't super sure about
at the time we're playing on being
historically correct hip-hop was
historically correct on this episode the
incredible Timothy Ferriss stops by
[Music]
yes give me one second here it is giving
away these shoe who's getting these some
great kid yeah first pair I ever wore
being shipped out to be part of
notification squad on Instagram make
sure you set your notification 60-second
Club we're just having fun with it it's
just a lot of fun
gamification just like fun literally fun
part of it I think it's funny that you
have to lose equipment in the first 60
seconds you know I don't think it brings
any value I think about value is fun and
escapism fun is a big thing so turn on
your notifications on Instagram I'm
always doing a ton of stuff first
fitness going through this box switching
up first pair I ever wore I'm getting
sent out mohamed hassan enjoy a brother
love you oh is that right even better
yeah listen get a good look at this
maybe there's some sort of scuff people
can prove this was actually yeah here it
is
0:01 first pair there it is let me put
on this one to son or his brother if you
you might be able to make some money on
this one day if I can continue to bring
value to the I have complete
understanding that what I'm saying
doesn't always encompass everyone
specific circumstances you want to
acknowledge of doing the best
in its most basic form I want to use
some of these ideas and expressions to
further a conversation or allow someone
to experience better the personal unlock
to see things differently from with a
different perspective I just want I just
want you to look at the bright side the
best of my ability inspire others to
have access to another mindset that I
found valuable in my own life as a
practitioner of these ideas I'm trying
to give you advice that has worked for
me the reason I differentiate my content
is that I can have greater articulation
on a number of specific issues with
video and get to hear what I'm saying
which is often which is always
improvised and only captures my thoughts
in a single moment one of the things I
find most fascinating is that even
though I document everything you still
only get to see one to two percent of
what's really going on you are here in
one sentence in one meeting during one
day the funny thing is the vlog I
produce is only 15 minutes of the 15
hours of work all in all you actually
don't get to see that much so the reason
why I do a podcast and a blog in quotes
on Instagram to produce these articles
so that I can give you the most nuance
to my ideas and perspective and the
differences of each platform quotes on
internet might not always capture the
full story which is why I'd like these
articles to expand those ideas and go
deeper into the details you have to
analyze context and look at the bigger
picture I'm always trying to assess what
works in culture and deploy my creative
in a way that makes sense for the
context of the room
currently quotes on Instagram daily work
there one piece of the puzzle that have
enormous impact for what I would
consider the most motivational outside
the blog podcasts and articles of where
I can get a lot more tactical way about
what I'm trying to convey I can't write
10 pages on legacy put it on Twitter
I can't always articulate follow my
thoughts and it ain't over and for me
those nuances and that context is
important a lot of people want to judge
me and make assessments of a single
piece of content they see but the truth
is it's all about context you have to
watch my videos and read my articles
listen to my keynotes to really
understand my twists proposed for too
many videos online that's where the
message is that's where the mindset
couldn't put in quotes there pins in
parentheses or something there and also
say or you don't because I know you guys
have options and time but to get the
full picture that's the reality of the
situation it's like a great meal at a
restaurant you're more than welcome to
just judge it on the green peas without
taking the consideration the glass of
champagne that we gave you when you
first walked in the music that was
playing the smiles from the bartender
the color of the linens the peas
before-mentioned peas as your first fish
the the main course the dessert the wine
selection the service and the treats we
sent you home with and the follow-up
phone call we gave you two weeks later
to see how it was you didn't see the
whole thing that's how I think about my
entire content strategy it's cool right
it's true
[ __ ] you know what's even more true you
guys both consumed my content a lot of
it and you had no [ __ ] idea until you
got inside the vortex even remotely
close to how deep and real it is right
from consuming it to working directly
with you and then filming
yeah the filming is the crazy right
what's the most intense give me this
that's let's look this game is gonna be
the meat of the episode so what filming
it what basically just I get to observe
every moment every minute every meeting
everything you mumble everything and so
what's the that makes sense so what's
the app what's the early observations of
what that what what is that what does
that give you clarity into or what's an
observation and don't sugarcoat it to be
nice
well basically I went from consuming as
a fan and on my mentor to then working
directly with Gary with you team Gary
team Gary to then filming it being on
the inside
seeing the way your mind runs your whole
thought process behind everything and
the meetings all the conversations you
have so what have you learned one of my
favorite things to do while filming you
is just observing the door
observing what you observed hmm so for
instance today you had the first podcast
yes you did
Gary no Chuck is in the building what's
up man and you mentioned something about
the shoes yes and you're gonna give him
a pair of shoes and then you and then
once you said 13 yeah I said they're
teens I don't have any sneakers but I
wear socks there's respect it's done
guys and they said you know surprise me
whichever ones they want the you want
the leather of the fly bit okay yep you
look at shoes second thing good I'm
proud dude you just made the blog good
did you look at shoes real quick and I
know just in my mind Tony like you just
want to check out his style
just once get some chow so you know what
that is you know how I always talk [ __ ]
that I'm listening more than it looks
like that's a perfect example that's
exactly that's super interesting good
job you just made the vlog good yes cool
let's go what's the title great let's go
publish it
[Music]
do you know do you know if I had a wish
besides good health for all of you it is
that I wish people understood what they
felt like when they were older that
would be such a gift because it would
slow down the whole game he'd be so much
more thoughtful because that's what
you're running up against when you're
when it's early you know dollars or
things that you need what you know
whatever check box your family and your
DNA created in your mind and we're
racing against it and it's such a
short-term arbitrage and it creates such
bad behavior if you guys knew what it
felt like to be 15 years older than you
are right now you would get real patient
and that would give you huge advantages
wrapping up heading home family stuff
[Music]